all right guy Richie been holding out
hope that he'll recapture the magic of
snatch that's the movies acted a little
dirty than I intended
doesn't matter point is like a man in a
loveless marriage I've been faithful for
two decades so now the gentlemen here we
go
[Music]
the gentlemen so the gentleman is a new
Guy Ritchie movie like I said in the
intro the movie more or less stars
Matthew McConaughey and oh how did it
how to describe it how to explain it
I'll try he owns a weed growing farm he
wants to sell it he wants to retire also
you have Hugh Grant's and he's telling
the story of how things went down but
you don't really know if it's exactly
how it went down it's very Guy Ritchie I
mean you just look at snatch yeah it's
kind of about a boxing promoter and a
diamond but if I were to break down all
the bullet point plot points of snatch
I'd be here for about as long as the
movie snatch is it's kind of like that
in this movie so you have McConaughey
you have a weed farm you have crime you
have some murder
you have story unfolding some unexpected
situations that derail some plans and
there you go well first of all the cast
is great Matthew McConaughey Colin
Farrell Henry Golding Hugh Grant
Michelle Dockery I didn't know I was in
love with until this movie but
apparently I totally am I so movies do
they teaches things Charlie Hunnam which
I'll admit I haven't seen a lot of
things with Charlie Hunnam I've seen the
Guy Ritchie King Arthur Pacific Rim
which I love Pacific Rim you know that
in that movie is all like we drift
compatible I've seen three seasons of
Sons of Anarchy I'm going oh man I've
probably seen a couple other things that
I don't remember but that's kind of my
point Charlie Hunnam and the gentleman
is my favorite Charlie Hunnam I have
seen today yes his one scene in
particular where he is monologuing and
he is controlling the room which brings
us to the dialogue this movie has some
sweet memorable quotable dialogue which
once upon a time was a guy Richie staple
when this movie is going it has that
energy that you want in a guy Richie
movie like this I will say sometimes
that energy is it seems to be energy
that's going all over the place like
that ball of the electricity from the
90s that you got in Spencer's gifts
right we're like okay a lots happening
and sometimes it's not as easy to follow
the plot what if you stick with it it
does steer you back on course well it's
the fact that when I walked out of the
movie I was like well the characters and
snatch seemed more iconic to me but did
they the first time I watched snatch
this is the first time I watched the
gentleman like I'm like ah Boris the
blade Franky four fingers cousin a V
bullet-tooth tony iconic but did i know
their names immediately when i walked
out of snatch and the theater i don't
know it was a very long time ago
honestly matthew mcconaughey in
particular I feel like he's a perfect
fit for a Guy Ritchie film but Charlie
Hunnam and Colin Farrell when they're
talking [ __ ] in the movie the audience
in this movie was laughing harder than
I've heard an audience laugh and a lot
of comedies lately
that could have been a little more
polished in parts maybe 15 minutes
shorter but undeniably this is the most
fun I've had in a Guy Ritchie movie
since his gold standard snatch with the
gentlemen there are a lot of players in
this game a lot of scenarios thrown at
you you have to pay attention and you
probably have to see the movie at least
twice but for a movie that almost makes
you have to watch it twice I'm looking
forward to seeing the movie again so I
want to watch it twice
this is Guy Ritchie returning to form
[ __ ] those studio pictures don't do
Disney movies do this guy ritchie's what
you're good at this is why people love
you
it's the colorful characters the sharp
dialogue the quotable dialogue and the
ride they all take you one that speaks
to a specifically Guy Ritchie experience
all right time to write this movie up
but before I do got to thank the sponsor
first of all to keep the suspense going
second of all for you to get some good
headphones so I'm so sure this video is
brought to you by Ray Khan recon earbuds
are those slick stylish earbuds you've
probably seen on the internet whether it
be from other youtubers influencers
celebrities like Snoop Dogg he loves red
cause I think I named Rob snoop last
time doesn't matter because doggy style
sounds great in these things great
cosmic doggie style sound great that
should be a slogan break on earbuds
started about half the price of any
other premium wireless earbuds on the
market their latest model the e25 that's
these it has six hours of playtime
seamless bluetooth pairing more bass and
a more compact design that gives you a
nice noise isolating fit no annoying
dangling wires connecting them never
again am I going to get Bluetooth
headphones with the shoestring wire that
connects no done with that I much prefer
these they also come with a variety of
fit options I appreciate that and they
come in a variety of new fun colors and
for me to use story timer icons they're
legitimately my workout headphones I'm
not one for New Year's resolutions but I
did promise myself I would eat healthy
and work out starting in a new year so I
suppose that's a New Year's resolution
but among any of the workouts I've been
doing these babies have never fallen out
of my ears not once and it is known that
for a good workout you need a killer
playlist and reliable headphones facts
so click the link in the description
below save yourself 15% off your
purchase and thank you again to recon
for sponsoring this video I appreciate
it and now to write up the gentlemen
funny enough I can see this being a
movie that's even better the second time
hopefully it is for right now I will say
the gentleman was a great time no
alcohol required best I can say is know
yourself know what you like if you like
Guy Ritchie old school Guy Ritchie if
you like Lock Stock and Two Smoking
Barrels and or snatch give it a shot you
might like this if you do not like Lock
Stock and Two Smoking Barrels
or snatch I don't think this is the one
that's gonna make you be like ah but I
do like the gentleman to just know that
all right so the gentlemen have you seen
it why did you think about it or what's
your favorite Guy Ritchie movie whatever
it is whatever you think comment below
let me know and as always if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
[Music]